Well, let's go through it.
This is, again, a tricky quiz because it requires two kinds of reasoning.
each string, we have to figure out whether it's in r or not and also whether it's in P or not.
We just saw in the previous quiz that unbalanced parentheses, like this single open,
are not in P. This is looking good so far.
For it to be part of the answer we want, we'd have to show that it is in r.
If we look carefully, in fact it is. Here's how I'm going to do it.
For this first opening parentheses for this star, I'm going to repeat it one time.
Then for this closing parentheses for this totally different star,
I'm going to repeat it zero times.
I'm going to end up with one open and zero closes.
This unbalanced open parenthesis is in the regular expression,
but not in the language of the grammar.
How about this balanced open followed by close?
Well, that is in the language of P.
I apply rule one and then rule two to get rid of the P. I fails our second clause.
How about this? Open close close? This is unbalanced.
The scales would be tipped to the right. It's not in P. We're looking good so far.
Is it in r? Yes. For this star, I'm going to repeat is once.
For this totally unrelated star, I'm going to repeat it twice.
Both of these--open-open-close-close and open-open-open-close-close-close--
they're all in P, so they're disqualified because of clause 2.
In fact, all of the strings here are in the language of r.
It's just that these three are also in the language of P.